Now is a really exciting point in time
for be to being a tech entrepreneur
because you always have to be operating
in a moment of disruption if you really
want to do something big right so when I
came to Silicon Valley the worldwide web
had just happened right and web 2.0 know
that wave was starting when I started my
career and people rode that wave Google
etc right uh and then there's this kind
of wave in like 2007 right the emergence
of the mobile phone and Android and and
iPhone and there's a huge new disruption
wave that really reset industries right
so you had companies like WhatsApp and
Uber etc being built uh which have
changed the world in many ways and I
think now the thing about that's
exciting for me about AI is that I think
we're in the first right I think that
there's this amazing disruption
happening and chaos. Let's call it
chaos. That disruption people use a lot.
I think it's kind of a dated way. It is
chaos. It is total chaos. Like nobody
knows what's happening, what's what,
right? A lot of people sound smart about
it, but I think every day something
changes, right? And I think that's like
a perfect uh uh atmosphere for
entrepreneurship because that therefore
what happens is young company clarity
young company can disrupt incumbents,
right? because incumbents are trying to
find their
[Music]
footing. Wonderful. Well, Manish, it is
so nice to have you here with me in 20
minute leaders. Thank you so much for
spending this next 20 minutes with me.
How are you? Good, good. It was great to
be on, Michael. I'm a big fan. I know
you're prolific in these episodes. I
feel like you're over a thousand at this
point, I'm guessing, but it's awesome to
be on the show.
Well, really nice to have you here. So,
you're you're in SF. I'm in Tel Aviv and
uh I'm really excited to to get to know
you better. H you've done such awesome
things throughout your career. I'm
really looking forward to unraveling,
you know, the the the bits behind the
big, you know, the the big labels on on
these great places you've been at from
Stanford to Google and and you know, so
many more and and what the work that
you're doing today. So, so again thank
you very much for being here. Manish,
tell me a little bit about you know
yourself in your words and and what
really what what's been really exciting
for you and your journey. Absolutely. I
mean I feel like uh I've hit the lottery
many times in life if you think about my
journey. So my family is from East
Africa, Uganda. Uh I was born in the UK.
I grew up most of my life in rural
Kentucky and very kind of uh you know
farms, tobacco fields, that sort of
thing. Uh moved around the US a lot. uh
was lucky enough to go to Stanford like
you. Uh I got a scholarship uh and uh
changed my life. Uh my freshman year was
1999 uh kind of getting to Silicon
Valley right after the.com bust. Just an
amazing time to be in Silicon Valley,
you know. Uh it kind of had arrived on
the world stage and uh my eyes opened to
the power of technology. Uh after
Stanford, I got lucky again in life. I
joined Google in the early days right
before the IPO. I was one of the early
product people there and there's just so
many wonderful, incredible people to
learn from when you're, you know, 22
years old and it's just this amazing
juggernaut. It wasn't even a thing yet.
It was a good company, but it wasn't
this global juggernaut yet. And so, uh,
was given outsiz responsibility relative
to probably my capability, but it was
amazing to go and build all these
products and work with amazing people,
uh, including one of the founders very
closely. And then in my late 20s, I
became a venture capitalist. accidental
venture capitalist. Uh I wasn't like
you. I was not very thoughtful about my
career. I kind of just randomly ended up
in venture and just fell in love with
the craft. I think the industry has to
evolve a lot. I think, you know, working
with entrepreneurs every day. It was
just so amazing. And I just, you know,
now I've been in venture about 14 years.
I started my own firm uh almost now five
years ago, four or five years ago. Uh
NAVA or series A firm based in Silicon
Valley, New York. Uh and then the other
part of my life is uh about 10 years ago
I was invited back to Stanford and I
joined the faculty there and I teach in
the school of engineering and design
school and that's just been so wonderful
to give back to the university I've
gotten so much from. So that in a
nutshell is a little bit about me and
incredible things to unpack. You you
said that you that you feel like you won
the lottery multiple times. Yeah.
Le let's let's say dig into those and
what what are those moments that that
make you feel like okay I mean yeah
these places seem great and yeah joining
Google before the IPO and Stanford and
the design school and and getting into
venture and now having your own venture
firm you know on the paper they seem
great there's also a lot of challenges
with them but what what is it really
about these experiences that that make
you say wow I mean this was this is
really foundational and formative for me
yeah I mean I think one thing I realized
in my journey and being in all these
different places, different walks of
life is uh people are the same
everywhere. And you know the brilliant
people in Silicon Valley, they're
brilliant people in East Africa, the
brilliant people in Kentucky, there's
not so great people in Kentucky, not so
great people in Africa, not so great
people in Silicon Valley. And I feel
like from the beginning, you know, uh
being able to be surrounded by just
like, you know, amazing family that was
supportive. Uh that kind of helped me
realize who I am and the potential of
what you could be. I think about that a
lot because I have a young daughter as
well and like you know how you raise
somebody matters so much more I think
than schooling or accolades or anything
like that. So I think from the early age
having that from 0 to 18 you know and I
think that there's so many mil in
Silicon Valley you know going to
Stanford open the world the eyes my eyes
to the world of technology right uh you
know calculus is calculus whatever
college university you go to right it's
the same same stuff but being at
Stanford it was being around these
people that I think that had this idea
of like two people three people in a
garage can build a little bit of
software that can change the world And
it's okay to try. Like winning is
trying, you know, and kind of really uh
understanding that. I think some
cultures don't allow for that, you know,
like trying is failure if you don't win,
you know, and so it's very conservative.
And I feel like that ethos of
entrepreneurship, pushing yourself to
imagine what can be. And I think that
was also kind of exciting for me. You
know, there's very different world where
you know, you could just go collect
accolades as many kids from Stanford
otherwise do and end up becoming
investment bankers or this and this and
just you keep stacking up all these
things on your resume, but does it
really resonate with who you are as a
person? So, I feel like early in life I
was fortunate to find technology and
technology found me and that was really
my language. You know, uh I really do
believe that products change and define
the world. uh sort of like uh you know
there's this this kind of Church Hill
said this thing the architecture shapes
our lives and sort of how we think about
the world. I think today's architecture
is products and the products that we
interact with whether it's your Android
phone, your iPhone, your Mac really do
have a significant impact on how we see
our lives today. So all that was sort of
lucky to be around those things and kind
of find kind of my people and my
language. Mhm. You're you're so you're
talking alluding and alluding a lot to
the creativity and the and the ingenuity
of creation of of building products.
You've gotten the chance to be a part
of, you know, some of the creation of
some of the most meaningful solutions
that have given space for what's
happening today. What what's happening
today in your eyes, you know, in the
world that we're living in, the agentic
era? Oh, yeah. That's that's happening
then. And what so what's happening here
in comparison to I guess your experience
in 99 and what's changed what stays the
same what's augmented what's missing
absolutely I mean I think now is a
really exciting point in time for be to
being a tech entrepreneur because you
always have to be operating in a moment
of disruption if you really want to do
something big right so when I came to
Silicon Valley the worldwide web had
just happened right and web 2.0 know
that wave was starting when I started my
career and people rode that wave Google
etc right uh and then there's this kind
of wave in like 2007 right the emergence
of the mobile phone and Android and and
iPhone and there's a huge new disruption
wave that really reset industries right
so you had companies like WhatsApp and
Uber etc being built uh which have
changed the world in many ways and I
think now the thing about that's
exciting for me about AI is that I think
we're in the first inning right I think
that there's this amazing disruption
happening and chaos. Let's call it
chaos. That disruption people use a lot.
I think it's kind of a dated way. It is
chaos. It is total chaos. Like nobody
knows what's happening, what's what,
right? A lot of people sound smart about
it, but I think every day something
changes, right? And I think that's like
a perfect uh uh atmosphere for
entrepreneurship because for that
therefore what happens is young company
clarity young company can disrupt
incumbents, right? because incumbents
are trying to find their footing and
their technology allows you to have
leverage in a new and exciting way that
you could never have had before and grow
really fast and so all those types of
things allow for an opening of the
aperture for entrepreneurs to do
something great and I think that's you
know you can never time when you're born
right going back to this idea of being
lucky in life I'm really lucky in life I
was born where I was born you know that
like my my father and my family had the
ability to move from India to Uganda etc
right if I was born 100 years ago know
that would have been tough you know who
knows 100 years from now and so I think
as an entrepreneur timing is so
important right and that's that luck of
timing right like the fact that you were
born when you were born you know you're
able to take advantage of all this AI
stuff you know I think it's it's it's
really exciting so I think the wave
right now this chaos of AI is amazing
for entrepreneurs
I I couldn't agree more and you know
timing is everything and it and it feels
like we're living in a time and we're
not the only one's having this
discussion many are having the
discussion of you know what is this what
does this agentic era mean for for the
integration of human computer
interaction I spent a ton of time at my
time at Stanford on human computer
interaction it became a almost an
obsession of mine to consider how are we
going to interface with these
tools you know I I remember you over the
last decade watching from the early days
of the assistant of Google Assistant and
I was watching my father, you know,
speak to the to the assistant in the
early days, you know, you know, almost
religiously and replacing his behavior
from from from textbased experience even
though almost nobody else was doing it
because there was it was still a lot of
friction. It wasn't that good yet, but
but he he realized that that was going
to be the new experience and he was
already bought into that idea. So are so
the way that humans uh behave and and
talk, move and experience is changing
and and I want to to hear a little bit
about your experience. I mean you teach
in the design school the introduction to
human values and design. Yeah. I mean
this is the one of the biggest questions
we have today. What are human values in
designing these new systems that we're
building? And you know just a week ago
to finish the thought you know or two
weeks ago Bessemer sent out their big
report on you know verticalized AI with
a big doubling down on voice a whole new
modality of interaction. So Manish I'm
really excited to hear your thoughts on
that. Yeah. Yeah. Um I I don't think
people know what the future is. I think
a lot of people can write a lot of
reports and things right but I I I who
knows right the way I think about it is
maybe one step one more layer of
abstraction I think the best
technologies disappear into our daily
life they become the fabric of how we do
things and you don't see them as
technology anymore right so if we look
let's take a historical look right uh
the steam engine you know when it was
invented wow that's technology now it's
just it's a train right the television
set right you know back in like the 40s
and 50s that's technology now it's just
a TV you don't think of as technology
right like a mobile phone right like my
daughter will not think of a mobile
phone as technology even if they exist
anymore who knows right but but like
that's not technology it's just the way
you do things right I was lucky enough
to be uh part of the team that built
Google maps in the early days and I
remember growing up I would look at maps
on a globe and I'd be like oh I'm a
small point on the globe and you know
that's cool but now maps if you think of
most young people they think of Google
maps on your iPhone or your Android
phone is a map. It's not technology.
It's just the map, right? Um, so it's
changing a lot. I think it the best ones
disappear into how we do things. And so
when I think about all this agentic
stuff right now, I think it's all novel
and interesting, you know, but I think
it'll just become the way we do
something, you know, like it won't be
like whether it's an a an agent doing it
on my behalf or whatever. It'll just be
about how do I get the task done I want
to get done. And by the way, a lot of
the task I want to get done will just be
done for me. I won't even be thinking
about that anymore, right? I won't be
thinking about how do I make the order
to like buy some food or whatever. It
will just like happen, you know? Um, and
I think that's really the the most
exciting part of it because the question
for me becomes as we start to deploy
these great technologies and they become
part of our daily life, do we get time
back? Where do we put that time? Because
at the end of the day, I think the best
technologies are solving for latent
human needs. And that's one of the
things I talk a lot about in my class at
Stanford. I think oftent times we spend
a lot of time when we think about
technologies around thinking about is
something feasible you know what's the
cost etc. We talk about compute all day
long with AI, right? We talk a lot about
business value, that kind of thing,
right? But I think the thing we don't
talk enough about is the human side. And
what is that latent need? What is that
deep need that you're kind of
addressing? It's not just about saving
me time, but is it about bringing me
happiness? Is it about entertaining me?
Is it about finding something else
that's more meaningful? The best
companies I think really spend time
thinking about that and like they solve
big problems that way because then it
becomes very sticky you know. Um I think
if you don't spend time thinking about
latent human needs and you just do
superficial things it's harder to become
a generational company.
No, I I I I I really hear what you're
saying and I think it's it's amazing to
me how we're in a position that on one
hand we see a dramatic shift in our
frame of thinking from how do we get
things done to now saying okay we're
going to get it done in a really
seamless way and now it's a question of
how do we it's not it's going to be a
non-issue. It's it's not about the how
it's about the what. Then you're taking
it a step further and you're saying you
know we're already at a position where
those companies that are simply solving
those those from how to what on the
dayto-day stuff that's okay with the
really interesting companies today are
already ones think okay from these set
of companies can I distinguish the ones
that are going to drive a really
important behavior change and and you're
alluding to some significant I think
valuesdriven changes that are that that
resonate obviously with how you think
what with what you think entrepreneurs
should be doing. Yeah, absolutely. I
mean I think these companies that are
being built today will the ones that
will last be the ones that are really
students of the human behavior side that
build new habits right they're thinking
deeply about you know what is the
problem that not that I just need to
solve today but is really something that
can last over periods of time and I
think about habits a lot because I think
whether it's an enterprise company or
consumer company I think it's all the
same you know I think it's actually
about the end of the day there's a human
being building with your tooling or
you're an infrastructure or a consumer
and are they going to build a habit on
it, right? Are you making their life
easier? Uh even if it's infrastructure
company, are you making that easier to
deploy something, right? A dev tool,
etc. That layers of abstraction because
at the end of the day, they want to just
go to lunch. They want to build
something cool, right? Everybody does,
right? They don't want to become a a
kind of a product manager understanding
the coolness of your technology. I think
consumer companies too, I don't really
want to understand like all the buttons
and filters and stuff. I just want to
share a cool piece of content with my
buddy, like make it fun and make it
interesting and then like let's go,
let's move on, right? And I think if you
think about that, those are the best
companies that really are sticky. Yeah.
No, and I and I love that, you know,
it's really about the the distilling
what is the part of the product that
creates the value. It's not the extra
features, the bells and whistles. It's
about what am I trying to get done? Can
you help me get it done? and do we have
now an opportunity to get it done in a
more fun way that drives me more
happiness, more value and and just
getting it done is not going to be
enough because that's going to be a
available for everybody. So Manish, I'm
excited to hear you're you're you spend
a lot of time, you know, meeting a lot
of companies and thinking about AI and
thinking from a from a design
perspective, you know, what are the
types of things that you are really
excited about today? Yeah, absolutely. I
you know I think that that we're in such
early days of AI and I that as as a
whole for me is super exciting because
people say this idea of like oh this
Cambrian explosion so many different
kind of creatures are being built all
over the place and I love that. I love
that. I think that, you know, the fact
that we even looked at like DeepSeek
from a couple months ago and it shook
the market cap of Nvidia, one of the
most valuable companies in the world,
right? It's kind of crazy. This random
noise from China can like shake this
company. It's like, wow. So, we really
are in these early days. The thing that
I'm I think you know what I'm excited
about is I feel like the last three
years have been about infrastructure
building the tooling allowing people to
now do the really exciting stuff which I
think is building the consumer companies
the layers of abstraction have happened.
So now a young student out of Stanford
who maybe is like semi-technical but not
a PhD in computer science can really
take advantage of some of these agentic
tools or AI infrastructure and build
something very very quickly and iterate
and that student that young person is
going to be much more focused on solving
the problem from a human lens than
somebody who might be more in the weeds
on the infrastructure right that's
important too there'll be value created
there right think about companies like
data bricks etc those are good companies
those are old companies that's that that
layer has been building for a long time
so I think when I where the most the
value will acrewue will be this pendulum
swinging from enterprise and
infrastructure over the next call it 3
years to these consumer experiences
which now you can build very very
quickly we saw this pattern by the way
uh years ago you know with the advent of
AWS and the cloud right and making it
very easy for people that you can build
a company very leanly you don't have to
be as technical as you would have had to
been 10 years ago to like rack servers
and go in a data center etc. You just a
few lines of code and oh my gosh there
we go I can deploy a service to the
world globally and it scales. Wow,
that's exciting. And I think that's just
going to speed up more and more. So I'm
really excited about this new type of
company that's going to be built. The
barrier to entry is just getting lower.
The opportunities are just getting
broader and deeper and and it's and it's
a builder's world now. It is. It is.
Whoever is willing to brands dirty.
Totally. And what I'm really exciting
about maybe which is maybe uh somewhat
contrarian for venture capitalist is I
think there'll be companies built that
touch billions of people that will never
require venture funding. It will be very
small lean teams of people you know call
it five six people that can build
services very quickly that scale
globally very quickly uh and never will
require the kind of venture capital
investments that we've historically
seen. And I think that's amazing for the
ecosystem. I think it's going to push
the limits of like how people think
about product. Absolutely. And and and
it could be that we will experience a
shift in in you know what you know where
where you know what are the models of
building a company in the in the
research layer, in the infrastructure
layer, in the services layer and then
the application layer. and uh and we may
be on the brink of a big transformation
of of of what does it mean to have
access to building a company in those
higher layers. I don't know about the
lower ones. I think those are pretty
still pretty difficult to build but but
certainly the higher ones definitely.
Manish, I I really want to thank you for
your time. Thank you so much for joining
me. This was a a privilege and an honor.
So, thank you so much. This has been so
much fun, Michael. Really appreciate it
and thanks for having me on. Thank you
so much.